I actually think that we have to destroy
the universities in this country they
get too much money they have too much
power I don't think they do anything
good American universities have become
hedge funds billion dollar hedge funds
that enriched the academic Elites while
they keep shackling students in more and
more depths and at the top of them all
is Harvard with a hedge fund of 51
billion dollars get this according to
data from the United Nations that puts
Harvard as the 82nd largest economy in
the world right behind Lebanon and
Tanzania which means Harvard is bigger
than a hundred other countries in the
world with that big of a hedge fund
Harvard should be able to pay its 55 000
tuition for every single one of its
students literally forever that's right
if all Harvard did was earn five percent
on that money Harvard would be able to
pay for all its students tuition forever
but does any of this hedge fund money
ever reach students no every single year
Harvard increases its cost Harvard
couldn't even offer a discount where
they move other classes online from the
pandemic and Harvard isn't alone Yale
has almost just as big of a hedge fund
at 42 billion dollars and Stanford has
an almost 38 billion dollar hedge fund
but as the academic Elites you would
never call your hedge fund a hedge fund
no God please no no the word hatchman
has a negative feel to it we gotta call
it something else something vague
academic boring sounding something like
an endowments ah yes endowments that are
meant to support the teaching research
and public service missions of our
University it's a fun use to support
future Generations there we go that will
bore someone to sleep when they hear it
but the reality is endowments aren't
about education it's not about
supporting students investing in the
community no it's about money status
business a tax-free business at that up
until 2017. I believe that the
university endowments in this country
currently have six or seven hundred
billion dollars of wealth that they're
managing what do they do with that what
is the point
I I wish that I knew Harvard paid their
hedge fund manager I mean endowment
Chief 6.2 million dollars in 2020.
Harvard's former president Drew G Foss
made 3.6 million dollars in 2018 and
Vanderbilt University's Chancellor
Nicholas Zappos Kika a near 3 million
dollar bonus after budget cuts and
layoffs their endowment 10 billion
dollars while the students from 1980 to
Today college tuition increased by more
than 1200 while inflation it's up only
236 that extra a thousand percent had to
go somewhere and it definitely didn't go
towards the students so while you're
slaving away trying to pay off your
student loans while working a job you
didn't study for the academic Elite are
getting insanely wealthy off of these
hedge funds while asking your parents
for more donations get them to sign on
the line which is dotted stay dangerous
and let me explain
I have 69 812.47
000 ninety thousand dollars thirty five
thousand dollars three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars sixty thousand dollars
worth of student loans my minimum
student loan payment is a thousand
dollars a month it should take me about
ten years to pay that bill I will be
roughly 36 be 45 years old I don't know
how old I'll be when I paid that off I
was actually on campus at Penn State and
I saw that I had so much to pay I didn't
know how to do it I never saw a number
that big funny story I actually dropped
out of college it was after I landed a
remote coding job that I had always
dreamed of see I learned the super
basics of coding in college but it was
nowhere near what I needed to know to
actually land a job and that's when I
found this insane course on how to build
a web app from scratch it was insanely
thorough and easy to follow I went to
the course built and launched a
functioning web app put that app on my
resume and boom I landed an 80 000 a
year coding job at 19 years old without
a degree or burying myself in debts and
the best part is that this course didn't
cost a thousand dollars it didn't cost a
hundred dollars now I paid less than
twenty dollars for this course I turned
less than twenty dollars into literally
tens of thousands of dollars all within
the span of a few months and it was all
thanks to the amazing platform I found
this course on called udemy
udemy changed my life I cannot imagine
where my life would be today if it
wasn't for you to me and all the
affordable courses this platform offers
we are heading into a recession right
now and the only thing that is
recession-proof are your skills so
there's three courses I want you to
check out on online MBA course is super
good the second is a python coding
course which is the easiest coding
language and the third is the web app
course I took because it's still super
relevant today so pause the video and
click the link below to get those
courses now this video is proudly
sponsored by udemy now back to the video
[Music]
have universities always been used as a
front for secret money making schemes
actually no back in the 1970s
universities were pretty innocent they
spent their money responsibly and the
amount of money in their endowment fund
stayed more or less the same but then
the 80s happened
movies like Wall Street came out people
became enamored with high finance and
hedge funds became a thing and took the
World by storm hedge funds were the
Slick new Cutting Edge investment
vehicles that everyone just had to get
in on everyone including universities
like Harvard and Yale see a lot of these
new hedge fund managers happened to be
Harvard Yale or Stanford alumni so these
hedge fund managers went back to their
universities and made a proposal you're
sitting on a bunch of cash you don't
know what to do with so why don't you
throw some of it my way and my hedge
fund will invest it for you so you
University is accepted I mean come on
you can't say no to alumni so you start
depositing huge amounts of money into
their hedge funds we're talking 100
million 200 million 300 million on top
of that you own hedge fund managers to
manage your endowments called endowment
paying them based on performance
suddenly universities started seeing the
potential of endowments especially since
these big universities are non-profits
which means their endowments were
tax-free at the time which gives them an
insane advantage over everyone else that
does have to pay taxes on their gains so
before you know it this strange merger
of hedge funds and universities started
taking off
[Music]
audacity to say corporations don't pay
taxes but no one has the audacity to
call call our colleges while they pay
this much taxes March Madness zero in
taxes football zero in taxes they get
away with all of that and they get to
charge parents more money every year and
press your parents to finance their
house and take money out you're
absolutely right let's say you're one of
these rich hedge fund managers that are
taking money from universities come tax
season you're gonna get hit with a
pretty gnarly tax bill but fear not
because we can simply donate the money
we would have paid in taxes to a
university endowment and then boom you
just got a huge tax write-off for your
charitable donation and if you were
smart and strategic about your donation
maybe you donated to a university that
has given your hedge fund money to
manage maybe you donated to a university
that you've been trying to give you some
money and boom money that would have
gone to the tax man went to an endowment
you get a tax write-off that University
may have sent some more money your way
to manage and you end up making more
management fees off of that money too so
the money just goes in a big profitable
Circle it's a classic case of I scratch
your back you scratch mine you donate
the endowment fund and somewhere down
the road the endowment fund manager
invests huge sums of money into your
hedge fund this might be partially to
blame for just how much University
endowments are invested into hedge funds
today the black color represents the
percentage of money universities have in
hedge funds so not only are academic
Elites getting rich off the backs of
indebted students so are hedge fund
managers like Yale University who in
2014 paid 430 million dollars to hedge
fund managers while only putting 170
million dollars into scholarships
but little do universities know that
hedge fund managers don't have their
best interests at heart
[Music]
so as the academic Elite your endowment
fund has been growing like crazy and you
and your colleagues couldn't be happier
but there's a minor detail you missed
when you signed your money away to these
hedge fund managers hedge funds are
horrible investments in fact hedge funds
are a great way to increase your odds of
underperformance see hedge funds have
What's called the 220 rule where hedge
fund managers get a two percent
management fee of all the money they
manage and 20 of whatever profit they
make now on the surface this sounds all
fine and dandy but the reality couldn't
be more Sinister see two percent might
sound innocent enough but what most
people don't realize is that compound
interest works in the opposite direction
as well and a two percent management fee
is a lot more than it sounds like but
that twenty percent fee for whatever
profits they make is the real kicker see
this 20 fee only applies to profits they
don't get charged a 20 penalty when they
lose your money so if you're a hedge
fund manager and you know that you're
going to make tens of millions or even
hundreds of millions without lifting a
finger and on top of that your only
other way to make more money is to get
insanely High returns without suffering
any of the losses out of your own pocket
what are you gonna do you're gonna take
on as much debt as possible make the
most psychotic trades possible in hopes
of hitting it big and hey if you crash
and burn no skin off your back you made
your Millions maybe even billions and
you get to walk away scot-free
these are the people that universities
have entrusted with helping future
generations and Harvard learned this
tough lesson during the 2008 financial
crisis when their endowment took a giant
nosedive with the majority of those
losses coming probably from how much
money they have in hedge funds but
that's okay because you know you can
just you can just raise the price of
tuition and cut the wages of can of
characters to make it back
is an economic crisis after all and
don't forget these hedge funds like to
keep their clients locked in for the
Long Haul so even if your returns start
to suck you still have to pay insane
fees until the next Redemption period
when you're allowed to withdraw your
money
the University of Pennsylvania just
jacked up the cost of undergraduate
attendance by 3.8 percent to just under
fifty thousand dollars a year
why'd they do this in the middle of the
worst economic downturn since the Great
Depression why do the people running pen
my sister's alma mater think they need
uh make tuition even more expensive and
you'll love this
you know why because their endowment
lost 19 of its value in the second half
of 2008. in 2021 Harvard had 33 of its
endowment invested in hedge funds
[Music]
um
one problem that you're going to run
into with your endowment is that
inevitably you're gonna have to invest
in things that aren't so politically
correct Harvard's endowment indirectly
invests in private prisons through
Vanguard the University of Texas quote
received over 600 million dollars from
an oil and gas Fund in wingler County
end quote Harvard Yale Princeton all had
money in a hedge fund run by a
billionaire who is a large holder of
Puerto Rican debt while at the same time
Puerto Rico schools were facing
crippling Cuts this is pretty bad not
because you've invested in these things
but because you've bred an entire
generation of college students that are
complete social justice Warriors against
this stuff
if they find out about your sketchy ties
they're gonna protest and Screech out
the word that every University hates to
hear divest divest from these unethical
Investments so you need a way to hide to
obfuscate your hedge fund from these
less than kosher Investments and you're
gonna do that with what's called blocker
corporations a fun little term for
offshore companies set up in secrecy
Haven so endowments can grow their money
in secret as the New York Times reported
quote a trove of millions of leaked
documents from a Bermuda based Law Firm
Appleby reflects some of the tax
Wizardry used by American colleges and
universities schools have increasingly
turned to secretive offshore Investments
the file show which let them swell their
endowments with blocker corporations and
avoid scrutiny Adventures involving
fossil fuels or other issues that could
set off campus controversy end quote
today University endowments have amassed
to over half a trillion dollars
worldwide and all that wealth all that
influence is concentrated in a small
group of elite private schools how small
11 of universities in the U.S hold 74 of
all the endowment money in the world and
it was only in 2017 that the government
started taxing endowments of large
universities the tax rate
1.4 percent while the average American
the average American gets taxed over 14
for slaving away at their job
what can we say helping future
Generations Never Felt So Good
[Music]
[Applause]